what's the super hexagon does it really
help us remember all the trigonometric
formulae and identities we have seen so
far yes it does it's a simple hexagon
which looks like this all we need to do
is join all the opposite vertices and
that gives us three diagonals we write
the number one in the center it's still
difficult to believe that one hexagon
can lead us to so many formulae to know
the formulae we give the six function
names to each of the six vertices but
there is a particular way in which we
need to write it we start writing from
this vertex go around the hexagon and
end at this one it's simple we just draw
a hexagon join its opposite vertices and
write a one in the center now let's see
how we write the six functions at the
six vertices we just need to remember
one formula which we have already seen
tan is equal to a sine by cos we have
used this formula like a zillion times
now tan is equal to sine by cos we start
at this vertex and write tan sine cos in
the clockwise direction tan sign costs
now three functions and three vertices
remain we write cot opposite to tan
remember cotangent opposite to tangent
what remains is cosec and SEC if we draw
a vertical line through the center of
the hexagon we will have three vertices
on the left and three on the right so to
remember what's written on this vertex
just remember that we have all functions
starting with C on the right side so we
write a Cossack here and what remains is
SEC that's all you need to remember
about how the super hex has to be drawn
three diagonals joining the opposite
vertices the number one in the center
and the six function
at the vertices so let's draw the super
hex on a new page a hexagon with three
diagonals joining the opposite vertices
the number one at the center Dan is
equal to sign by cause got opposite to
tan cosac here since all C's are on the
right and what remains is SEC are you
ready you're going to learn a whole set
of trigonometric formulae this video is
fun but also very long as we will be
covering most of the trigonometric
formulae we have studied before
to understand the first set of formulae
let's try going around the hexagon in
the clockwise fashion we go like this
this tells us that tan theta equals sine
theta by cos theta well that's how we
started making our hexagon now let's see
the next three functions in clockwise
direction these three this tells us that
sine theta equals cos theta by cot theta
the first one equals the second one by
the third one take the next three
functions clockwise first equals second
by third hence cos theta equals cot
theta by cosec theta and if we take the
next three functions we can say that cot
theta equals cosine theta by sec theta
and we will get two more formally if we
go clockwise coset is equal to SEC by
tan and SEC is equal to tan by sine
wasn't that simple one hexagon and six
formulae without any effort great but
what if you forget that you had to go
clockwise and you go anti-clockwise
instead let's say you started like this
in the anti-clockwise direction don't
worry the pattern still holds true first
will equal second by third tan theta
equals sec theta by cosec theta
first equals second by third if we take
these three functions anti-clockwise we
can write sine theta equals tan theta by
sec theta if these three then cos theta
equals sine theta by tan theta and the
list goes on whether you go
anti-clockwise or clockwise
first will always equal second by third
we can easily get three more here one
simple hexagon and twelve formal a is
that all no there's more let's draw the
super hex on a new page to understand
what else there is we draw the super hex
and write a 1 in the center tan is equal
to sine by cos cut opposite to 10 as we
have all C's on the right we write a
cosec here and what remains is SEC in
the previous set of formulae we did not
use the one which was written in the
centre let's see why it is placed like
this if we multiply the functions at the
opposite vertices we get a 1 this
multiplied by this equals 1 sine theta
multiplied by cosine theta equals 1 this
multiplied by this also gives us 1 cos
theta x seck theta equals 1 and this
multiplied by this also equals 1 tan
theta multiplied by cot theta equals 1
so when functions are diagonally
opposite vertices are multiplied we get
a 1 wait there's more
we draw the super hex right the number
one at the center tan equals sine by cos
cut opposite to tan and Korsak here
since all C's have to be on the right
and what remains is SEC I repeat the
positions again and again so it gets
etched in your brain
after watching the video take any three
continuous functions in the hexagons
like tan sine and cos tan x cos will
give us sine so if three continuous
functions are taken the product of the
first and the third functions result in
the function in between them we can say
that tan theta multiplied by cos theta
equals sine theta take these three
functions for example this multiplied by
this will give cosec so SEC theta
multiplied by cot theta will give us
cosec theta even cot x sine will give us
cos cosec x tan will give us SEC and so
on first term x the third term will give
us the term in between them does it end
here not yet
let's redraw the hex again with one in
the center tan is equal to sine by
course got opposite to tan cosac here as
all C's on the right and what remains is
SEC now focus on the functions add
diagonally opposite vertices sine n
cosec cos and SEC cot and tan they are
reciprocals of each other
look at this arrow for instance this
arrow tells us that sine theta equals
one by cosec theta what about this arrow
this arrow tells us that cos theta is 1
by sec Teta and this arrow tells us that
cot theta equals 1 by tan theta if the
arrow is drawn like this we
even say that Cossack theta is
reciprocal of sine theta so remember
functions and diagonally opposite
vertices are reciprocals of each other
be patient it doesn't end here but let's
review what we have covered so far this
equals despite this or this equals this
by this this x this equals 1 or this x
this equals 1 this multiplied by this
equals this and this is equal to
reciprocal of this let's draw the super
hexagon to know the other stuff it tells
us tan is equal to sine by cos cut
opposite to tan cosec here as all C's
are on the right hand side and the
remaining function set here do you
remember complementary angles yes two
angles are complementary if their sum
equals 90 degrees and the trigonometric
functions had a special relation with
complementary angles you get this arrow
what does it tell us about sine and cos
it tells us that sine of theta equals
cost of 90 degrees minus theta this
horizontal arrow tells us that sine of
an angle is equal to the cosine of its
complementary angle similarly this arrow
tells us that tan theta equals cot of 90
degrees minus theta and this arrow tells
us that SEC theta equals cosec 90
degrees minus theta and if the arrow is
drawn this way it will tell us that cos
of theta equals sine of 90 degrees minus
theta so a horizontal arrow tells us
that one function of an angle is equal
to the other function of its
complementary angle I think I have lost
track of how many formally the super hex
has helped us remember and there's more
this is the super hexagon with a 1 in
the center
dan is equal to sign by cos cut opposite
to tan Cossack is written here as we
have all the C's on the right hand side
and the only remaining function SEC is
written here look at the figure there
are six triangles formed inside focus on
three this one this one and this one
let's zoom out slightly okay so here we
go clockwise within each of the
triangles starting with top left
position like this sign cost and one
this gives us one very important
identity this squared plus this squared
equals this squared so sine squared
theta plus cos squared theta equals one
now let's go clockwise in this triangle
this squared plus this squared will
equal this square one plus cot square
theta will equal cosec square theta if
we go clockwise in this triangle we get
tan squared theta plus one equals sex
squared theta
amazing isn't it this arrow can also be
drawn anti-clockwise from the bottom of
the triangle like this the only
difference with anti-clockwise is that
there will be a minus sign before the
second term so it will be this squared
minus this square equals the squared so
we can say that 1 minus cos squared
theta will equal sine squared theta
similarly if these two also became
anti-clockwise we get two more results
Hoess x squared theta minus cot square
theta equals 1 and sex squared theta
minus 1 equals tan squared theta now you
know why we call it super one hex again
helped us with so many formulae in
trigonometry but hang on you have to
practice this procedure well because
there are a few things you need to
remember here too
the position of the functions the
directions of arrows and so on this
video is not a substitute for all the
other videos done before this it's just
an add on memorizing formulae can never
be the solution make sure you understand
all the formulae we derived in the
previous videos